so cute he was a rescue a lot of clients
come in and they've rescued animals it's
always amazing to work these guys do
they adopt these animals out so they can
get there forever home and then he goes
home and lives Halfway Around the book
you know it's funny now I can remember
my time when we first started this job
right we want to take everything home
and we did and it came to the point like
okay everything come in the clinic every
animal we can't take home and to get to
a point you have to kind of tell
yourself no because you want to take all
these babies home when they're so cute
they're so loving and you just want them
all this one is a living but we get to
enjoy everybody else's pets that is the
beauty of it and we don't get in trouble
for having too many albums exactly
[Laughter]
right now
as business at the clinic hits its
morning stride a patient drops in out of
the Clear Blue Sky hey man what's going
on
[Music]
oh I'm doing good bro how are you what
you got in here yeah I got a little Hulk
I found in my yard this morning oh that
is gorgeous tea check out this burger
all right took my dogs out this morning
and they kept barking and they were all
three around a hawk I think his wing
might be messed up he didn't try to fly
away or nothing you got any better I was
trying to figure out how it got there
maybe it was flying with this mama and
it got tired and fell down and crashed
landed I don't know but I knew it was
worth saving so and brought him here did
you see him holding either one of the
Wings up or out I saw him holding one
out the right one okay gotcha the other
one looked like it was functioning
pretty good just rotate here I'm gonna
definitely let you know what's going on
taking pictures though okay we
definitely got a game with a little
Taffy juice
you want to definitely make sure you
treat these wild animals of Georgia just
like you treat any other domestic pit
I'm gonna put it on the anesthesia and
get an x-ray see exactly why he's not
flying that Comfort all right we'll keep
that gas in there tea you know we're on
Paul's side so he giving out the orders
you know what he said what stick your
hand in the hole hey you know what would
be real funny he's really just kidding
you you know you got four thousand
degrees and then you're here with your
fingers stuck in there just sticking my
hands in the hole whatever you do don't
leave okay you're pretty good on the
whole plug too
Paul you better hurry up you kept your
fingers on the hole yes sir please stay
asleep yeah he's still asleep
tell them good job man thank you
I need more of the head please let me
hop up go ahead and shoot it all right
ready
[Applause]
oh boy
looking at the legs I see a vertebrae
that's
inflamed here everything looks good
there no breaks
looking at the X-rays I see some would
look like compressed vertebrae and while
I got this bird out cold I'm gonna take
a look up under the feathers and see if
I see any other types of obvious ones
but I only have a short window before
this bird wakes up so I gotta hurt do
not let this hole wake up
just trying to see if we got any micro
fractures here you can see an abrasion
on his eye here we got hit across I'm
turning it let's go he waking up I just
saw him move right now all right so he's
waking up I think let's get some Bay
Trail on board
awesome I'm lost the camera paint on
board there's trauma right around the
head and that I'm sure there's a
concussion I'm just glad I don't really
see any breaks in that net I want to
make sure that we don't have any
swelling in the brain also I want to
decrease the amount of inflammation in
this bird's neck you waking up welcome
to the light Mr Holt you gonna be stuck
at hotel Hodges for a few days see if I
can get you turned around we also need a
little bit of time or TLC all right come
on in my friend all right we have a
little injury to our neck and I think
that's a trauma we got abrasion across
here the action wings oh look good they
look great I gave him a pain shot and
you did a great job for this great state
of Georgia oh wonderful all right you
free to go I got you covered thank you
all right the doc's going to take care
of them give them medicine nursing back
to good health and hopefully he'll find
wherever he was going I'm gonna let you
be for the night
[Music]
the crew is off to a house call that
hits much closer to home it's a pretty
big man I'm excited to see the farm oh
yeah you haven't been there y'all went
half these on this property I own nine
and a half nine and a half calories
okay and I help with them oh you got a
donkey out there and what about the guys
you bought the donkey
this is how you gotta negotiate yeah
okay but then when they dropped the dunk
off they say oh yeah by the way she
pregnant you'll both have your own dog
right now it's a half a doctor
[Music]
so we aren't really treating somebody
else's cows we're treating our cows my
plans are to bring keys from all around
the country here teach them not only
Veterinary medicines but agriculture
no but I I've never been hmm I'm excited
what's the game plan today what are you
doing so we couldn't vaccinate one yeah
OCC
OTC will stay good so
OTC you got to get vaccinated and then
we want to see if they gain a little
weight since last time cool let me hear
your best cattle get up
so when you get them in You Gotta Be You
Gotta Be uh hell let me hear your best
yo
ahead of time what you got man come on
yeah you got to be nice with it like
come on
all right man so I guess we'll all right
yeah let's try to hang everybody up yeah
yes sir we decided everyone on the phone
for about 25 years ago however it took
us 25 years to reach that dream we're
just starting out so we have 19 heifers
that are roughly about a year old come
on over here some of this good food come
on
I'm Farm manager Sean does an amazing
job when we're dealing with cattle
they're very spooky they can be
especially with the young ones that we
have so what we have to do is bring them
up with our feed and then we'll start
just closing Gates behind them and try
to force them into the area that we want
them in all right
there all right
so 441. OTC OTC awesome not in a good
way not in a good way come on girl come
on now we're gonna be through this one
time you're hoping to get her in this
time and actually get those vaccines on
board and hope it's not like last time
last time boy she wreaked havoc on us
and havoc on the shoot just like the
Critter figures every little click has a
troublemaker
Paul
um let me hear you say Let's Go Kai
let's go Kyle y'all there you go oh yeah
there you go it works
7 56. how much how much 7.56 so I'm 56.
all right what 7 40. 16 pounds 16 pounds
if we can get individual weight it tells
us a lot how they're eating um it even
tells us about their health you know
definitely they're not gaining and
everyone else is gaining there's
something going on we need to look a
little bit further so it allows us to
keep a real close eye on the herd and
know exactly what's going on all right
hey you ain't gonna get the best of it
this time that's right she did not get
her vaccinations the last time they get
upper respiratory infections they get
clostridium and they get tetanus so it's
very important that we get this vaccine
on board
appreciate you thanks girl no and uh
good job
she put on about 16 pounds yeah almost a
couple pounds a day oh that's good so
what you think Paul I know I usually
have you in the surgery room what you
think I like it out here man I'm a good
door man
I wouldn't shut it then we can turn you
into a farm yeah that'll be Paul though
man it feels so good to leave iPhone yes
iPhone yes say it our phone iPhone I
don't want to leave I don't know we got
to go they're looking good though that's
right keep the gain on
we're gonna find your boyfriend real
soon big old muscled up boyfriend
we got something in there
good boy
nobody's gonna hurt you baby they're
gonna make you better hey hey I don't
know how you guys doing yeah how are you
it's a better days huh yeah yes sir all
right so what happened here Dumpling ate
a stuffed animal
dumpling is 10 years old he's getting up
there but he's still our baby and we
love him he's a sweet boy he swallowed
his sister's stuffed animal clock's
ticking hopefully we can retrieve it
it's about this long and probably about
that big around it happened about three
o'clock it really depends on where this
thing is but we need to get it out of
there initially what we're going to do
is try to shoot an x-ray to see if we
can pick up anything we may initially
try endoscopy which is basically run a
light or two down the throat and see if
we retrieve it that way and take one
step at a time here okay let's hope we
beat the clock yeah is it in pieces or
he ate it in one big he swallowed it
okay come on handsome I'm not good for
animal eat a stuffed toy a foreign body
something that can block the intestinal
tract and cause them they'll start
vomiting and even staying there too long
then it can cause issues with the
intestines so it definitely be something
that's very detrimental
yeah
good job
it's a good looking dog I'm Griffin
dress in there whatever it is and then
metallic gonna do it
what y'all thinking the head of stuffed
animal I was hoping that maybe a zipper
on it or something on if I can identify
where it is but I don't know three yeah
[Music]
that's planned you take him back in and
get our stuff together yes the X-rays I
really was hoping that there was
something that was metallic there or
something that was very dense didn't
give me something clue that is still in
the stomach but it wasn't anything so
it's probably just Fabric and cotton
which means the X-ray kind of shoots
straight through all right
did you see it don't see anything so
what we're going to do is we're going to
do an endoscopy and see if we can
retrieve it from the stomach if it
hasn't already gone so we're gonna have
to get some anesthesia of course if that
doesn't work and we can't get it to pass
it's going to have to have surgery
hopefully we don't have to do that so
keep your fingers crossed and throw some
prayers up all right absolutely the
doctor said he's gonna do the endoscopy
hopefully we can see the toy inside him
get it out go home happy dog happy
family hopefully we have a happy ending
foreign
[Music]
a lot of times we have objects of
foreign bodies there we may be able to
retrieve them without having to
physically go into surgery and be
invasive all right let's go
hurry
are we feeding here we go in
there we are almost there there's some
resistance yeah slightly did you turn it
a little bit there you go there we go
all right so we're getting by the end of
the stomach here there you go
oh that's it right there that's it
oh that's it grab that thing let's put
the claws through we see the object
inside the stomach now they're trick is
to see if we can grab it and pull it out
of here
it was definitely a lot better to be
able to pull it out the way it came in
instead of having to do surgery because
if we can get it out this way the baby
wakes up we can go home if we have to do
surgery you have to open up and the baby
may be with us for a few days all right
so you can take this now I can open it
and what is that right yeah a piece of
grass what is that yeah that's grass
right there it looks huge
all right well let's um pull back
and maybe we can get kind of in the hole
right there
go back a little bit
a little more there we go there you go
grab that thing got it got it
there you go
big you getting some resistance
resistance oh man
I think it's just
nothing big I don't want to break this
line
broke off
I think the prize too big for the claw
come all the way up we gotta do that we
got a pizza
yeah I ain't coming through the house
so all right well we know what it is
unfortunately we can't get the toy out
with endoscopy it's just too large and
it's wedged in there so I need to go and
talk to the clients to let them know
we're really only left for one option
which is surgery
hey hey whatever it is too big we grab
it but it will not come back through
there with the saliva and fluid they're
probably swollen it's bigger than it was
when it went in but we're going to go in
there and get it out that's the only way
can't get it out with the endoscopy so
when can you do the surgery you're on
the anesthesia we're just going to stay
sleeping okay I'm gonna get gown and
gloved up and try to get in there and
get it out we'll be right here okay
we've had dumpling for 10 years we got
him when he was just a couple of months
old we just love them to death so he has
to pull through this this is the hard
part waiting
I will tell you Dr Ferguson is a good
surgeon so we're gonna be in and out oh
gosh you don't think I'm jinxing no no
no no I got confidence in your surgery
ability we get finished we really got to
get this stuff to out now we don't want
to go any longer because we leave it out
any longer could cause some permanent
damage I got confidence in the surgery
doing surgery on a gastrointestinal
system there's always risk it can
develop what we call peritonitis the
inflammation of the lining of the
abdomen and that can be deadly come on
here you feel it yeah in the stomach
still
I have it here I'm just trying to
exteriorize it
and then that's all that thing man it's
like a baby like I said that's why I was
about to pull him off the table yeah all
right hold that Jordan we found the
object we're getting ready to make an
incision and take it out I just hope I
don't have to make a huge incision in
the stomach now I see why you couldn't
turn it it wasn't you too impacted yeah
it's rolled all over until then all
right let's see
that is huge
oh we just had enough for tonight right
there man we've never got that thing out
wow that's huge huh he ate it oh he
swallowed that yeah he swallowed it if I
went down his esophagus but he can have
it yep
he wasn't coming back out the other way
though well that was fun
unbelievable if we didn't see it with
our own Outlet
all right let's try to sew this baby up
and we're gonna awaken here once we open
the abdomen and then pull that stomach
up and I saw that large object in there
definitely going in and doing a
Gastronomy was the only way this thing
was coming out everything went well the
great thing here is the owners had no
doubt that the baby had eaten this far
and body have you not known you know it
could have been a week from now and at
that time the in the intestinal tract
would have caused the dog to have a lot
of pain develop a bacterial infection or
peritonitis and they could have died
all done look at that that's it Yep this
thing was not coming out of there let me
tell you once I saw that thing I knew it
wasn't coming back out I swear to you it
was not this big when it was oh no I
believe you it got it and got soaked and
it expanded he made it through good yes
sir we are in recovery now we may be at
a discharge in the morning
all right Dr Fergus did a great job I
could not believe how big it was when he
swallowed it it was small but it's not
as small anymore
[Music]
damn my boys
well we're happy campers now because
we're going to have our family back and
dumpling is going to be back in his
place without a toy he'll be a little
pound or two later
you gotta leave your sister's toys alone
no there won't be no toys for you to get
okay Mama gonna throw them all the way
[Music]
hey hey how are you I'm doing okay all
right let's see what's going on with
this baby yeah
um got a little bit of a problem I
brought Max in to see Dr Hodges for a
cat fight that he was in so what you
think man happened there he was playing
with his brother and I heard him kind of
meow a little bit I went to check on him
and then that's when we noticed
something wasn't right
got him pretty good it looked like it
got to the third eyelid and sliced it in
half okay
supposed to have a nicotine memories
which basically served as a windshield
wiper for the cornea but unfortunately
this poor kid's case is sliced in half
so it's scratching the corner and it
could possibly cause loss of visibility
or loss of design the eyes on there just
really really inflamed let me take this
kid about the surgery okay yes sir don't
worry thank you I appreciate it I'm a
little scared Max is going into surgery
I'm not sure what to expect I have good
faith in Dr Hodges that he can save
Max's eye there is a little fear in me
though oh no
see if we can say it is on me
come on buddy
all right Max so you just only messing
with the third earlier yeah
my plan here with Max is to go in and
remove this damaged third eyelid and if
we can remove this and there's no
corneal damage we definitely should be
able to save Max's eye have you been
able to take a good look at it yeah I
did the whole conjunctival is just so
dark on the flame it's torn third eyelid
and we can make you see better buddy
foreign
Southern ice pack I helped it yeah yep I
think we're gonna be fine
I think we got great news we removed the
tissue that was just really scratching
off this cat avoided a close call I mean
if you can imagine I guess right when
they blinked the third eye lid probably
came up and it took the brunt force of a
slicing pole that just sliced it in half
and now you can actually see the eyeball
now all we gotta do is do some medicine
get the swelling I feel like this is
going to be a great case
close call anytime
Costco
hey hey somebody's here sleeping like a
little baby well that's good to hear I
got that piece that was covered out that
was sweated and to be honest that really
was good news because that third eyelid
is what saved this cat's eye oh wow that
was the best case scenario now I know it
looked creepy and I Know It kind of
freaked you out oh it did I'm gonna keep
the baby overnight and we will go home
tomorrow but I feel very confident that
we're gonna save this eye
no problem I'll check on you later okay
bye-bye
amid the Spate of appointments today
ears nose and throat cases are all on
hold here so and if you know we had this
otoscope that we can project on the
television screen right but we got a
problem one of the employees washed it
in the laundry
if not it doesn't work anymore how did
that even happen these um young children
well they're gonna do better though not
anything you're not that didn't work so
you think rice will help me like the
cell phone or somebody's definitely in
trouble around here head out to Ferguson
what's up hey I was wondering if you can
look at this baby for me
um I brought Rango today he is a veiled
chameleon that I am fostering working
here has honestly been a blessing
because every animal that I take as a
foster I have gotten through Critter
fixers how many do you have I have two
he has a sister actually named Rosie do
you have them together no separate they
can't see each other yeah territorial he
came out of a situation where the lights
were not quite exactly where they needed
to be for Veil chameleons so I just
wanted Dr Ferguson take a look at his
skin make sure that I'm doing everything
right I'm a little concerned about him
though communion is a very tough animals
to keep and need to be sure that the
temperature is correct the lighting is
correct because all these things can
affect them metabolically and it can be
detrimental if these things are not
right so we need to make sure one of
them UVA and UVB okay so that's what you
have now that's what I have now correct
at least 10 hours there we go at least
10 hours yeah see this white scale area
here yeah so we're shedding that's kind
of normal they'll do it individually
unlike a snake where they share the
entire body they'll do it individually
yeah you hear that bug he is pretty thin
though doctor
because I've had him for about a month I
mean let's get down you can scale a
little smaller let's get away today and
then we'll wave periodically here to see
if we're gaining or to make sure we're
not losing it may take a minute you know
they aren't very large to start with so
even gaining you know like a couple
grams it's a lot so let's see where we
are now you gonna step on the scale
Rainbow
[Music]
he is a climber he wants to go to The
High Ground every time or maybe the
highest ground in here just don't get up
on this mountain top right here
now we can put him in and see if we stay
in long enough to get away here
so we're 72 grams a little thin how are
we eating and what are you feeding so
he's eating crickets and dubia roaches
he loves them he loves watching them
crickets try yeah
these guys you know just like the other
reptiles that we have like bearded
dragons they can also develop Metabolic
Bone issues a lot of it diet related all
right so what I want to do is I want to
wait like once a week okay and once we
get to feel like we're doing a lot
better you know we can find that forever
ever Home Ringo looks very thin in this
case I think it has a lot to do with the
stress that this guy's been under but
the structure look good the bone
development looked great it's just that
we need to put on some weight so we
don't get into these metabolic issues so
I think with just a little feeding a
little more time with her this guy's
gonna be doing good hopefully you find a
good home for him I can't wait Michaela
gonna keep this baby
so I'm talking to them
you take care of this I kind of blame
y'all though because I didn't know there
was a thing like reptile rescues until I
started working here I took the office
cat home and now I'm taking home
reptiles well look at you look at you
blame her I have full confidence that he
is gonna gain weight and so part of me
does want to keep Rango but I do want to
see him have his own forever home and be
able to take care of another pet that
might need my help a little bit more
than Ringo
I got it
it's gonna be okay buddy
can I get those mice
they're nice yes sorry
so would you just keep mice in your
pocket
tea so you remember the Hulk he had a
concussion we're looking much better
this morning so it's time to feed huh
time to see if it will eat maybe he'll
eat these little things treat no
concussion is always a game of wait and
see but one of the surest ways to make
sure they're feeling better is when they
start to eat hey
huh you're different responding a lot
better you see this Hawk started to
follow the food that's definitely is a
good sign
remember this is a bird I pray my friend
yeah yeah he definitely is a lot more
alert today he can walk I mean yesterday
he couldn't even walk
and then there's a mouse
[Music]
no
come on buddy
we're just looking at this Hulk the
biggest thing is trying to see if he
will eat he was in a pretty bad way
yesterday I just wanted to go ahead and
eat because if he doesn't he may be in
worse shape than he looks I don't know
about this dog can he eat bro
hey
you know what I was watching when you
eat
there we go oh yeah you like what's on
my menu I'm super happy from where we
were it was one of the cases where
client brought them in in their knees
and we were really worried about if this
bird would live let alone eat and fly
but he just ate a pink and he's about to
eat more look like we will on our way to
uh being back in the Georgia Skies
we're coming pretty good I love it I
originally thought that I may need to
get this bird to a rehab her but I feel
like if we keep getting stronger and
eating we'll let it fly right here from
Critter fix
foreign
[Music]
turn down
can you put cool in another cage
you know what the worst dogs in the
clinic making noise why would they be
about a heart attack right it gotta be
y'all make it hard to look bad you know
you're gonna move them they can't stand
each other but can't be without each
other until harder we're gonna charge
two-time boarding products all the
trouble we have today I agree that's
right matter of fact we may just ban
them from the clinic
thank you
it's okay you're fine
I'm working I ain't got time for all
that kind of stuff
[Music]
doesn't let the dogs
get good
I service dog Ava I have severe PTSD and
fear of people so for a long time I
couldn't leave my house Ava was
originally a rescue so not only did I
rescue her she rescued me because now I
have my college degrees which I couldn't
have done prior to having her hey hello
what's up what's up what's up I hope you
don't know talk to me on this baby she's
got right here on her knee she's got a
gross and she's got another one on her
foot she'll chew on it and the bugs
won't leave it alone she's got some
gross and some irritation on her skin
well I was worried she was getting yeast
back when I got her she looked like this
over her whole body
and they said it was yeast yeast
infections in dogs especially in the
warmer claims are quite common but I
need to take a closer look and see if
there's anything else going on hey
I know
it's a man and he's touching you service
dogs can be a little skeptical so I need
to really be careful so I can keep my
hands when dealing with this cute pup
are we licking our Paws yes constantly
so your primary problem is Georgia
give me one second okay all right come
on sweetie we're gonna make you feel so
much better Ava has something that I
constantly referred to as Georgia
disease and basically that's allergies
you agree with me huh they start to itch
once they itch it breaks the skin they
get secondary yeast and bacteria
infections Ava is a service dog we need
to get Ava fixed up in a hurry so she
can get back to her regular job
let's make an impression with tape
sometimes you use something as simple as
good old tape you just make an
impression and you're looking on a
microscope and you can see if you have
yeast type Impressions look at all old
school method so who do I know around
here that knows old school medicine
let me see if he still remember this
trying to see if you remember the old
impression Smith yeah with a little tape
you got in oh I think
about the skills let's see it's been
about what 75 years since you graduated
me right in here sir
[Music]
oftentimes animals would chew them and
it'll start to bleed so definitely need
to remove these raised leashes so we're
just gonna dead in this area I'm just
gonna put this in
we use lidocaine and deaden that area
around so the animal feels no pain then
I'm gonna cut these papillomas off all
right this puppy shouldn't feel anything
perfect
look at that perfect
great job puppy dog
oh you're the great surgeon which one
you think
pray at work
I think it's surgery you think is the
prep work and I think it's probably the
dog yeah it's a great dog just look at
the image it's already focused
you can see if there's some yeast there
the
really smoothly no no I'm too cool
[Music]
tears you see anything oh nothing of
significance
what's wrong with the patient
you can adjust the counters on this
elbow
that's what it is Alice on the elbow
yeah I know the callus just an old dog
with challenge but I mean some normal
bacteria here too okay but I don't see
yeast which is what I was thinking I
might see on the elbow I trust you I
don't nobody got to your left but I
definitely trust you
[Music]
doesn't see any kind of yeast so we're
probably just dealing with a secondary
staph infection I feel with some allergy
medicine and antibiotics this baby
should be excuse me really soon so cow
what type of shampoo would you recommend
we could do the keto condos one what
about the Chlor Hicks Chlor Hicks it's
four percent okay I've never seen that
one go look in the cabin I think that's
what I'm gonna go with okay I'm feeling
really good about it was prognosis we
got that little tumor all we got
something to control the itch hey what's
up man come on over here
so somebody's in my camera line actually
dancing on doing the the what you call
it
you like that one
so here with the Soul Train live man
come on
come on over here I'm done sometimes we
have the soul train line but seriously
though while I'm trying to take this
thing off he's over there doing my lab
work and vice versa so it ain't a
Critter Fixer it's pretty fixers
teamwork what made a Dream Work
all right there she is so there's no
yeast so we got that little tumor off
the answer is the problem which leads to
everything else yes
take this shampoo this is the one I want
I've used this that's good stuff yes
that's gonna kill all the bacteria and
everything on the skin okay you should
notice it pretty quick that it didn't
stop things went much better than
expected I'm actually quite happy
because with her background and her
history it could have been so much worse
and these are just our normal vaccines
yes sir she did amazing I mean like not
one growl back there let me see
you go over there the moment now
let's see all this thank you so much no
problem I've had a lot of vets that will
see Ava because they get down in their
face and she growls when she's by me so
they're like hands off and then they
don't give her a proper examination and
Dr Hodges ignored her and just did what
he needed to do
which was really nice
[Music]
it's cool Bunny look how great he looks
good morning Max
looking like a whole different cat
when I came in this morning and saw how
well that I looked and talk about
thankful so oftentimes those kind of
injuries end up in an animal losing his
eye I was fortunately able to save his
eye Max Vision that I is totally clear
and so I'm super happy what's up what's
up I got both of y'all at the same time
yes sir come on over closer I'm very
pleased
great to see his eye looking a hundred
times better than it was when we brought
him in and I just couldn't be more happy
and excited for him probably got yeah
they came up it's ready to pieces and
they missed the uh because if he had to
win uh then we would have been talking a
whole nother thing yeah and we've been
talking about taking on that yeah you're
all gonna have to put drops in and the
drops is getting the conjunctivitis down
we'll let you hold okay Mom here you go
a couple drops
so
perfect and we're just gonna do that for
a few more days awesome we couldn't find
any vet to help us out and Dr Hodges and
his team took us in right away and I
couldn't be more grateful and thankful
for them truly they mean the world to me
for saving Max and his eye no more fight
man no more fun I'll see you later thank
you you are very welcome
[Music]
carry on
Sierra can I ask you a question please
how often do you do laundry
my favorite the house no here
someone took the liberty to wash my
otoscope in the laundry Jordan sir I
heard something can I talk to you for a
second please
I have to be stealth around here to try
to figure out who it is because they're
going to try to pass the book have I
done any laundry yeah yeah cleaning
towels you know washing machine 10 years
here I'm sorry I ain't got anybody got
doing laundry around here especially
surgery laundry
do you do it you put stuff in the water
no you don't put stuff in the washer so
you did the laundry the other day yes
you sure yeah you sure you didn't watch
anything that didn't eat washing
oh yeah I do not typically do the
laundry so I'm good you're looking like
you know something happened with the
laundry what y'all got going on so I'm
gonna wash my otoscope in the laundry I
just know it's no Paul there's no
Sierras no Jordan there's no Richard
why are you looking like that
oh you watched my old school
[Music]
let's not touch first but we may not be
friends no no so you do laundry
I was up another night I got stuff all
over all over right and you always tell
me let me walk around her bloody clothes
I just threw all that clothes in there
so since you like to spend money when
you gonna buy me another old school CSI
Ferguson has solved the case Dr Hodges
with his late night clothes washing now
he owes me a brand new
otoscope I think they got a new model
too so you can just get nothing while
you order it's a little bit better now
this is detective Ferguson and you've
been watching Critter files
it don't pay the watch clothes
[Music]
it's okay you're so cute Animal Rescuer
Nicole stops by with a pungent pal we're
just going to see Dr Alex hello so what
you got today this is Mr B what's going
on Mr B so you know how sometimes I
don't have the full story yes I think
that's one of these okay I have a skunk
Mr B his name is Booker that was brought
to me by another rehabilitator they
think that it had been hit by a car when
I have him walk his back legs dragged no
no booger can't spray they have to lock
their back legs and his tail has to be
able to go up and one of his back legs
drags the other one can't stand and his
front legs can't hold full support
either
he's just so friendly
obviously he's hurting because his back
legs is definitely hurting in his disc
area I'm gonna go back in maybe let's
take a picture see if we can figure out
exactly what's going on with you I'll be
right back my example Booker I can
definitely tell he's having a hard time
ambulating we need to get this baby to
x-ray however if it's too broken up and
there's too much of pain involved we may
have to put this baby down all right
that's right
[Music]
oh man
this one's real it's bad huh let me see
what happens when I pull it all out oh
yeah Nicole sure
I got some news for you but it stinks
Hmm this hip is smashed
that is definitely what a lot of your
pain is coming from okay the whole back
leg is just Jacked Up In a Country Boy
Song so I'm going in try to surgically
get all of this bad degradation and all
this broken up bone okay I'm gonna try
to clean that out okay try to make a
false joint it's got a femoral head I'll
stick man I'm gonna try okay I've never
done one let's go I can't believe that
that's what this little guy was doing oh
my go ahead I mean it is I'm so sorry
there's a ball and sock in that hip
joint when there's a really a problem we
have to cut the head off and we make a
false joint I've done an fho many many
times on all types of animals but never
in a skunk all right let's go
I made my decision so
I'm trying to get in the Caps to see if
I can find this doggone thing
you want to be real careful when you
dissect here this thing is five Bros is
almost formed full calories you can see
the callus around the bone yeah see
that's why it's so Jagged that's why
it's so jagging that's why it hurts so
bad I know there's a whole lot of
fibrous tissue around that joint and it
was more than probably caused by some
kind of trauma that fracture this femur
some have to maneuver around and cut
this fiber Stitch wow but to be really
really careful because it's a nerve that
runs right through this area and if I
cut this it's a great chance that Booker
will be paralyzed there we go sweet yeah
that's the fiber stuff that
is causing all the problem I mean this
is Jagged and hard and it's totally
painful this will be almost like having
a jagged Rock oh Jagged Rock in your leg
and once you get that and you look for
the for more headers like there's a
church and there's the people look
inside and there's a seat
this is the head of the femur and this
is what broke off this is that ball
that is sitting right there
so there we go
yeah cooking with grease now nice and
smooth I ain't never did a skunk
Hey Joe
but it's like a textbook and Fat Joe to
me
let's take a home once I remove the head
of the femur the body has to heal and
start creating this false joint so that
hopefully Booker is able to start being
more mobile and move around I feel
really do this right can you look at it
yeah all right you can start waking them
up this fho surgery was a success
good luck to the skunk I didn't get
sprayed and I basically got myself out
of a stinky situation what's up girl so
look literally that is it fill out it
hard stuff yeah that's all the shatter
so that's all the shatter that's removed
oh look at it it's hard to see the big
thing now is just controlling the pain
making sure the inflammation going out
make sure we don't get any more effects
and wait and see okay am I taking him
home you taking him home yay I knew that
this skunk was a fighter with whatever
it was dealing with to be its age and to
have the attitude that it had so
whatever he was going to fight for I was
gonna fight for and I knew Dr Hodges
would feel the same isn't it so cute
though yeah it's super cute I'm so
grateful Dr Hodges always willing to try
no matter what animal I bring in I love
you it is so nice
hey
there's your time
you don't have to just bite me in there
you knowing on my finger a hamster look
hold on hold on I want that
you see it yeah hold up a snake
I am not a joke
all right I'm just trying to give him
some medicine I like I'm gonna say I
know I'm bleed so what happened to you a
little hamster man I'm holding him right
he just said first he did this then it
got hard either girl that's okay
right here
[Music]
you ready Dr Hodges and vet tech Paul
check on their concussed wild Hawk to
see if he's ready to conclude his stay
at Critter Fixer
what's going on
I ain't got no more mice you gotta catch
your own mice now
yeah
he ain't playing no games today it's a
big day for you fella it's only a couple
days of observing this Hawk I figured
this wasn't the case I had to send to a
rehab I can just send them on and let
them fly from critifix's backyard see if
he gonna fly put him on you perch what
you gonna do bud I've done my part so
it's the moment of truth now it's time
to see if this hawk Is Gonna Fly and all
healed up like I think he is let him go
there you go another awesome special
good job boss
good job I guess you gotta you can go
catch his own Mike now I feel nice yeah
hopefully I'll feel my for sure you got
a pretty big feel yeah there are a lot
of special moments here at Critter fixes
but it's really special when you're able
to release an animal back right into the
wild most clients and patients you don't
just take them outside let them go throw
them in there and let them fly yeah man
right there you see him yeah he find a
tree keeping myself perfect
almost
[Music]